ANAHEIM WAS THE KEY TO BOTH OF
THE ALONG THE
HERE COMES J.T.
>> ALEX NEWHOOK, A CLASSICS BUME
SITUATIONAL POINTS
HE COULD DO IT ALL.
HE'S ONEMacKINNON.
STRAIGHT BACK UP TO MAKAR.
HERE'S LANDESKOG LOOKING DOWN.
MacKINNON, CROSS-ICE HIT.
LOGAN O'CONNOR HAS IT.
AND SCORES!
[ HORN ]
>> WELCOME BACK TO LEAD.
>> WHEN YOU SEE HIM PLANT
HIMSELF LIKE THAT, NOBODY IS
OU !
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY FOR  BACK
ERIK JOHNSON, FEELING IT EARLY.
WW OFF --
SCORE!
[ HORN ] PLY, BUT CHANGE
>> WE HAVE A CHALLENGE HERE, IS.
>> IT SURE IS.
KIND OF CLEARLY TO THE
BLUE LINE.
>> HERE'S THE CALL.
>> REFEREE: AFTER REVIEW, THEGI.
REBOUND, SCORE.AT PUCK BACK
BUMPED RIGHT TO SUZUKI.
IT'S A POWERPLAYAY
BROUGHT AHEAD BY SUZUKI.
HE HAS TOFFOLI WITHU SEE 29
AND 92
LOOKING MacKINNON DUU TO GO AND
WE'RE GOINGNG
DOWN THAT RIGHT SIDE AND CUTTINS
MacKINNON.
MacKINNON DOWN DEEP TRYING TO
GET THE SHOT OFF FROM VAL NICHU!
THE AVS